shooting at its core in who knows of a
shooting at an elementary Sandy Hook
elementary school very scared worried
about my son in the wake of December's
horrific mass shooting at Sandy Hook
Elementary School in Newtown Connecticut
Vice President Joe Biden is chairing a
panel of experts who will make gun
control recommendations to President
Barack Obama by the end of the month
here are five facts about guns and
violence they need to know the violent
crime rate which includes murder rape
and beatings is half of what it was in
the early 1990s and the violent crime
rate involving the use of guns has also
declined at a similar pace despite
terrifying events like Sandy Hook or
last summer's theater shooting in Aurora
Colorado mass shootings are not becoming
more frequent there is no pattern there
is no increase as criminologist James
Alan Fox of Northeastern University
other data show that mass killings
peaked in 1929 across the board schools
are less dangerous than they used to be
over the past 20 years the rate of theft
per 1000 students dropped from 101 to 18
for violent crime the victimization rate
dropped from 53 to 14 over the past 20
years virtually every state in the
country has liberalized gun ownership
rules and many states have expanded
concealed carry laws that allow more
people to carry weapons in more places
there are around 300 million guns in the
United States and at least one gun in
about 45% of all households yet the rate
of gun related crime continues to drop
while many people are calling for
reinstating the federal ban on assault
weapons research shows that it would
have no effect on crime and violence
should it be renewed concludes a
definitive study the bans effects on gun
violence are likely to be small at best
and perhaps too small for reliable
measurement the Sandy Hook school
shooting is as horrifying a crime as can
be imagined it rips out the country's
heart and the call to action is strong
and righteous but as Joe Biden and his
panel of experts consider changes to gun
laws and school safety policies they
need to lead with their heads and not
just with their hearts over the past
dozen years too many policies the
Patriot Act the rush to war in Iraq the
tarp bailouts have been ruled by emotion
and ideology passing sweeping new
restrictions on Second Amendment rights
won't heal the pain
we all feel but just may create many
more problems in our future for reason
TV I'm Nicholas